You know, honestly, I wish people would just ask me, Hey Steven,
is this a good idea?
I'm about to sell out my entire brand for a few thousand dollars,
maybe even a few million dollars. Is this a good idea? And I would tell them,
uh, no terrible idea,
such as the case with Kevin O'Leary,
who has become a national embarrassment recently. And let me also say,
I understand that becoming a national embarrassment is hard to do.
Like most of us, we could never be national embarrassment at best.
I'm a local embarrassment to my mother, the friends who know me,
it's hard to be a national embarrassment.
You already have to be nationally known.
And so most people we don't even qualify,
but Kevin O'Leary definitely is in the running because he's already a massive
star. Thanks to shark tank. You guys know the show, right?
It's like the WWE of venture capitalism. People hate this.
I hate it too.
No investor comes on, pours out his life's work. And this is a bad idea.
They're always like, yeah.
I want like a hundred percent of your equity for $5,000.
Here's my offer for 100% of rock block.
And that's the show and it's fun. It's hilarious.
But one of the things that annoys me is the way that these sharks have been
selling out their reputations. Maybe, cause they're not getting paid enough.
Maybe they need a bigger yacht. Maybe they need a bigger house.
I don't know what it is. But now that they're all massive celebrities,
they've been selling out their image and moving totally away from this idea that
they had when they were sharks like, Oh,
we're no nonsense business guys into selling out their brand to the highest
bidder, no matter how scrupulous or unscrupulous they weren't.
We already covered Robert Herjavec who was caught in a little real estate
scheme. But you should also know other sharks are also doing this Damon, John,
uh, also endorsed Jason Bond picks, which if you guys know stocks,
you know what a joke that guy is. All right, listen, before I contacted Jason,
I'm a shark, right? You know, I have no problem about, you know,
ripping somebody apart or just saying I'm out. No, you're a sellout for money.
You know,
instead of having to go to the office every day and talking to a full staff or
worried about who buys this shirt or what new company I invest in,
I'm going to be sitting on my yard. Great. Well guys, it's that easy.
Just forget about a business trade from your guy.
So that's a massive L right there, but nothing is worse at all.
Pales in comparison to what I'm about to show you guys today because Kevin
O'Leary has taken sellout to the extreme and gotten himself on
cameo. Now guys, if you don't know what cameo is,
it's like a place where you can get birthday shout outs from the boy band,
from the nineties that you used to like, and your friend still likes them.
So you get them best wishes for a birthday or whatever on cameo for like 90
bucks. Okay. That's what you're supposed to do on cameo.
If you have an ounce left of self-respect,
what Kevin O'Leary is doing on cameo is charging $1,200 for business
outs for any business that you want.
Hey everybody, Mr. Wonderful here. Hey Mr. Wonderful here.
Hey Mr. Wonderful from shark tank here, busy kid.
And that's what training was all about. Millcroft lawn care pro Nossa.
It's a website that personalizes and helps you grow your business.
It's the only app where your kids can track their chores. You know, look,
please call Anthony or visit his website,
www Burlington lawn care.com. Now,
if you're a plastic surgeon, you're going to want to hear me on this thing.
I'm shouting out for service called plastic surgeon at experts.
It's been, you know.
What?
You're shouting out for plastic surgeon at hu uh,
Kevin, what do you know about these guys?
Besides the script they gave you to read?
You have to generate leads. You want to do that efficiently, productively,
and you want your customer acquisition costs to be as efficient as possible.
And that's exactly exactly what surgeon addicts parts do.
So check out plastic surgeon ad experts because they're
focused on your vertical. If you're a plastic surgeon, check it out.
I mean, am I crazy here? This is, this is embarrassing.
Like he doesn't even disclose the fact that he's being paid to do this, right?
Like if I ha if I'm shouting out, I don't know,
blue moon to use a offhand example. I have to tell you,
I'm sponsored by blue moon. I'm not going to say, Hey,
I'm doing a shout out for my friends over at blue moon. Uh,
they're not my friends. They're paying me to say this and look,
it goes on and on.
Hey Mr. Wonderful here.
And one of the things that everybody's thinking about is can I get a.
How are you shouting out now? Come on, Kevin, tell us who I'm doing.
One for side hustle app.
Oh great side hustle app. Paid them to do this. And why would he do this? Right?
Why, why would people pay so much money for this? Cause $1,200 is a lot.
If you're just going to keep this cameo to yourself.
Cause that's what cameos are meant to do,
but that's not how people are using Kevin O'Leary's shout outs.
And he knows that they use them to endorse their own business. Look at this.
Each trio gets a shout out from Mr. Wonderful shark. Tank's most beloved.
Kevin O'Leary gives a big shout out to Samantha, yell at him at Chile.
Okay. Check it out.
I missed a wonderful here and I love to celebrate entrepreneurship and I mean
globally. So here's a really interesting shout out.
Hey buddy, you're not doing a shout out.
You are doing thousands of sponsorship posts and selling
out your brand to trick consumers. Let's be clear about what you're doing.
It's not a, he like how he does that. Like, Oh, it's a great shout out.
Interesting. Shout out I have going on here. Not what you're doing, buddy.
Here's a really interesting shout.
Out. Look at this.
Kevin L they spelled his name wrong literally of shark tank endorses.
He trio and look, why wouldn't they say that they paid $1,200 to say that.
And Kevin knows. They paid to say that.
I can't even tell you how many people lately I've seen do this,
where they get Kevin alert specifically. He's like the King of this,
of these fake shout. I'm Mr. Wonderful.
From shark tank here has sold nearly a thousand different products on Amazon
alone. Check out Sophie's book. Thank you for the kind words,
Kevin.
There it is. You can pretend like the endorsement was all natural.
What I paid for it? What do you mean?
This is just what Kevin O'Leary me and Kevin O'Leary. We're just tight.
Like this we're just tight like this because he never says it's a sponsorship.
He just says it's a shout out. So you can do it.
This lady's doing and put it in your YouTube ad. Oh yes, dude.
He has sold out the soul of this show and just been like, Hey,
you know, it stood for real people,
making real companies forget all that I'll sell you.
I'll say you a shout out for $1,200. You'd get at me and look, he's done a,
he's got 157 reviews on here. And if you think that, you know,
on average, probably one in 10 people review a product,
we can actually find out how much he's made from this whole a sellout. Right?
So if a one out of 10 people actually reviewed it,
then when you have a 1500 people who actually bought it $1,200 a pop
Kevin O'Leary's made $2 million from his quick little sell out there.
And in honestly I do get the hustle. Listen, what I am going to say though,
is you have to accept the responsibility for what you do. So if you,
if all you want to do is shout outs on cameo. Okay?
But then you can't pretend to be the investor that we're all supposed to take.
Seriously. You can't be the guy whose word we're supposed to be like, Oh,
if he endorses that product, it's a big deal, dude.
This guy will endorse human poop. If it paid him $1,200.
And I'm not sure that that's an exaggeration,
even because Kevin has endorsed some doozies, dude, check this out.
This is done for you agency launch already. We see kind of Kevin over there.
We'll get to him in a second. But look at this guy, okay.
This guy is some 25 year old, nothing. And look at this picture, right?
Look at this picture that he's got right here. Now, do you know anything,
notice anything funny about this picture?
Like he's clearly talking to some interviewer or something like that.
Here's the laundry Brunner. Oh sure. He's wearing AirPods.
That's a little bit weird. Right? But I'm not going to hate on him for that.
But look over right. Wait, sorry.
I can't see properly. Uh, right here. See something wrong with that bookshelf.
This is a entrepreneur who has green screened himself
into a fake interview. First fake social clout.
This is a lie. It is a green screen set. Now listen,
am I going to judge someone with the green screen set?
You're right. I, well dude, you can't trust someone with the green screen set.
Let me be the first to say it.
And yet we have Mr. Sellout here who
approves the whole thing. Andrew poppy out is Mr. Wonderful unpro.
You know, was an incredibly powerful force if you know how to harness it.
So I'm doing a shout out for Andrew. Padea interesting entrepreneurial.
Oh.
Very interesting. Entrepreneur.
Don't you think Kevin probably done a lot of research into Andrew Bobby.
D's done that due diligence.
He's done the due diligence of the done for you agency launches five-year plan,
right? Oh yeah. Very interesting entrepreneur. Very interesting.
Of course digitally. This is when he's 21 years old,
Jim leads fast and he's become almost a consultant to those that use digital
platforms.
He's almost become a consultant, dude. You're reading off a teleprompter.
Kevin it's enough. This is embarrassing.
Stop it. Stop it. Like at some point you have sold out too much,
right? Like don't pretend you know, all this guy's history.
He's given you a script to read for $1,200. Let's be clear with the consumer.
What this is. Why should we respect these celebrity entrepreneurs?
If they're going to turn around and sell out their image for nothing for 1200
bucks, dude, I can't imagine. Listen, I get that.
He's making tons of money and God bless him for it. But for me,
it's kind of, it kind of ruined shark tank.
When I see all the entrepreneurs on shark tank,
selling out their brand for nothing. I don't know.
I want to hear what you guys think. Am I exaggerating things? I,
I honestly do think Kevin O'Leary for this for selling out his name this many
times that's this is national embarrassment territory. Like I said,
I know it's a stretch. I know it's a high bar.
Not many people have reached the Pantheon of national embarrassment.
Most people have only reached the state level or the local level or the
council, the city council level. But Kevin O'Leary, I think in my opinion,
he's gone all the way to the Tiffany Tiffany top.
We know what you guys think in the comments below and just remember guys,
you can't believe everything you see on the internet.
Don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
Yeah.
[inaudible].